hi there steve kaufman here  and i'm going to talk about my 10  secrets to successful language learning  and the first one is attitude  attitude determines everything with the  right attitude you'll spend enough time  to succeed  attitude is something you can control  so you know i like books but you don't  have to like books i like books so much  i got books all around my house but you  don't have to do that  but you have things that you like so it  might be that you appreciate the color  of a flower or food you're eating or  friends or family and you have to take  the time to enjoy those things and it's  the same in language learning learn to  appreciate certain things find things of  interest  listen read  you know have that confidence that  you're going to succeed and you will  attitude is the key at least the first  of my 10 secrets you want all my 10  secrets go to my blog the linguist.com  and subscribe